Gavin Newsom continues to be brutal and
ruthless in what I believe are all the
right ways he had that extraordinary
interview with Fox News propaganda Sean
Hannity which we covered he was
interviewed again this time by former
Biden press secretary Jen saki on her
MSNBC show and I want to play a
particular clip from that interview that
a number of you sent me regarding uh
mental illness and Mental Health crisis
Gavin knew some blames Fox News in this
clip
for uh making the Mental Health crisis
worse listen to what he says
I want to know your thoughts and I'll
give you mine take a listen
entertainment Wing particularly of the
Republican Party the surround sound on
Fox with these you know I don't even
like say his name Tucker Carlson or that
other I don't even know the guy from I
mean it's just like they're all the same
and what American news and Newsmax and
what they're doing to provide this
country to you know we're illusion rules
not facts do you occasionally turn on
Fox runtime and see what happens just to
see
occasionally um
every night every night and do you think
democrats should still be appearing on
Fox or should they not be a parent uh it
contributes to the Mental Health crisis
in the state so on the basis of one's
own personal conditions I would not
recommend it my staff is quite literally
trying to have interventions with me
about it they say I'm too obsessed with
it but I need to understand it you want
to know what the other side thinks so he
says Gavin Newsom says Fox News and
other right-wing trash media contribute
to the Mental Health crisis potentially
causing mental illness is that just a
funny line or is it actually a real
possibility well there's a number of
ways in which he may actually be on to
something there is an argument that by
exposing viewers to misinformation and
fear-mongering and fomenting
polarization based on lies and being
scared of scapegoats that they establish
that they are actually changing the
perception of reality that their viewers
have and that this thus affects their
emotional well-being and social
relationships and makes Fox viewers more
prone to anxiety depression
paranoia a potentially activating a
latent mental health issue like
schizophrenia or whatever the case may
be I'm not saying that's the case but
I'm saying is there an argument to be
made here that Gavin Newsom might be
right like for example there are studies
that have found Fox News viewers are
more likely to believe false or
unsupported claims about covid about
climate change about immigration and the
dangerous brown people that are coming
here or election fraud or whatever once
they believe those false things it can
cause confusion distrust fear and denial
of scientific realities distrust of
expert advice for example
all of those things can impact the
health including the mental health of an
individual another example Fox News will
often portray certain groups of people
on the opinion shows in particular but
on the news shows as well immigrants
Muslims liberals protesters marxists
anarchists as Donald Trump used to say
as threats enemies and criminals and
this induces fear and anger or even
hatred this increases stress levels
cortisol Etc impacts empathy fuels
aggression
this can lead to a mental health crisis
Etc so I don't have to belabor it but is
there something to what Gavin Newsom is
saying there ultimately obviously the
impact of Fox News on Mental Health
depends on a number of factors and
contextual realities and the
pre-existing mental state of those who
are watching Fox News in the first place
I'm not pretending Fox news is giving
everybody mental illness by any means
but is there something to what Gavin
Newsom said let me know in a comment let
me know in an email let me know on
threads where you can find me at
david.pakman did you know that anyone in
the world can very easily access a ton
of data about you online data Brokers
collect huge amounts of data about
everything you do on your phone your
computer where you go what you look at
but we recently learned that government
agencies like the FBI have also been
buying a ton of this data from data
Brokers just to keep track of people
without needing a court order criminals
can also use the information to Target
you ad companies and political
Consultants can buy it and try to
influence you but you can stop it our
sponsor incogni is an affordable service
that specializes in getting your data
removed from these sites incogni will
send data removal requests to the major
data Brokers they are required by law to
remove it upon request if your
information stays online incogni will
just follow up with them about removing
it it's that simple and you will be kept
updated every step of the way so you
know what's going on what Incognito can
accomplish is amazing I use it myself
and my audience gets 60 off go to
incogni.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman the link is down below